ôtez maroni comment il est aujourd'hui
je vais te faire découvrir l'académie
des dalons c'est un super projet pour
les jeunes qui va voir
si tu es jeune plein de talent et de
volonté et que tu cherches le ta voix
alors reste avec moi l'académie des
dalles on va sûrement beaucoup intéressé
[Musique]
construire un projet de vie révéler tout
son potentiel
ce sont les objectifs de l académie des
dalons cet accompagnement mise en place
en 2012 par le département est destiné
aux jeunes de 18 à 25 ans sans emploi et
non scolarisés nous allons rencontrer
des bénéficiaires qui s'épanouissent
pleinement grâce à ce dispositif bonjour
jacques faty bonjour alors tu as déjà
fait partie de l'académie des dalons
comment est ce que s'est passé cette
belle expérience d'un conte moi toute la
première partie en internat donc on dort
ici pendant trois mois on travaille sur
le développement personnel et la
deuxième partie c'est on l'envoie en
mission de service civique pendant neuf
mois une voie dans les métiers qu'on a
toujours voulu faire ou si on veut
découvrir un nouveau métier mais qu'est
ce que tu as pu accomplir grâce à ces
dispositifs donc j'ai pu intégrer une
crèche parce que j'ai toujours voulu
travailler dans la petite enfance tg
appris de nouvelles choses qu'est ce que
l'académie t'a apporté sur le plan
personnel alors quand je suis raide à
l'académie j'avais un gros manque de
confiance en moi j'avais du mal à
m'ouvrir avec les gens est aujourd'hui
bas grâce à eux j'ai réussi à avoir des
puissants qui confiance en moi merci ça
et faty et bonne chance pour la suite je
remercie
bonjour romuald pour jour alors tu es à
l'académie depuis maintenant deux mois
c'est ça raconte nous un peu qu'est ce
que tu vas faire aujourd'hui là on fait
ce matin on a fait un projet colle qui
est sur le harcèlement scolaire et avec
lui dans l'eau et c'est d'après midi on
va faire un théâtre forum en lien avec
l'enseignement scolaire aussi et en os
tel harcèlement scolaire ça touche tous
les jeunes et que ce soit fille ou d'un
garçon et du coup voilà ce qu'on veut
c'est un beau programme en tout cas
merci et retire au mali
[Musique]
avec deux sites à la réunion l'un saint
paul et l'autre à la plaine des cafres
l'académie accueille chaque année plus
de 80 volontaires tous apprennent à
prendre confiance en eux en leurs
ressources et en leurs compétences
claude calmer et responsable du site du
bernica il s'investit au maximum pour la
réussite de ces jeunes bonjour monsieur
calme est toujours alexandre alors tout
d'abord quels sont les critères pour
être admis à l'académie des dalons trois
critères principaux être âgés de 18 à 25
ans avoir un niveau 3e ou est dans une
situation où ce qu'on a fait ne convient
plus et le troisième critère c'est une
motivation changer ne commence pas c'est
l'accompagnement des jeunes un
accompagnement ça dure douze mois c'est
un contrat d'engagement avec des deux
droits et des devoirs trois mois
d'internât du lundi au vendredi avec la
découverte de son potentiel et 9 mois de
mission de service civique dans une
veine mission citoyenne et avec une
préparation au projet professionnel dans
cet internet quels sont les avantages de
l' académie des dalons pour ces jeunes
en recherche d'emploi la confiance de la
mise en situation réussite et de
l'identification de projets qui leur
correspondent merci monsieur calme et je
vous en prie
[Musique]
les responsables de l'académie des
d'alençon constamment à l'écouté des
bénéficiaires
il leur apporte du soutien et les
accompagne dans leur avancement
personnelle comme professionnelle les
jeunes volontaires peuvent ainsi
identifier le projet qui leur correspond
et bien s'insérer dans la société
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l' académie des
dalons n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes
les coordonnées qui s'affiche sur votre
écran le département des générations
c'est fini si vous souhaitez revoir cet
épisode ainsi que les précédents rendez
vous sur nos sites et nos réseaux
sociaux quant à moi je vous retrouve
très vite pour un nouvel épisode à
bientôt
la semaine prochaine je vous emmène au
coeur du café les aidants un moment
d'échangé et de discussion qui permet à
chaque aidant de partager son expérience
vous d'aller le voir l'ambiance est
conviviale les bénéficiaires sont
écoutés et surtout valoriser
[Musique]